foreign
David is with us in San Antonio hi David
welcome to the Ramsay show
David Ken how are you today better than
we deserve what's up
awesome
um so my wife and I we've been married
for a little over a half years we want
to get into our first house by next
summer when baby step four and five
right now we have a three-year-old and
we have another one on the way in about
two or three weeks so with that being
said our household income is at 157k
going into next year
um so we have been over the last you
know five years or so we've been
contributing money towards our house
fund and to grow stock mutual funds so
far we have contributed about 166
thousand dollars towards that house fund
but because of this
Market that we're in with the stock
market
um it's gone down about 30k so right now
we're about 135 000 in that house fund
my question
is
do we take that hit of that 30k to get
into a house in the next six to eight
months or do we just write it out you
know until we at least get I would say
at least half of that back in that in
that fund yeah
when are you thinking about buying a
home
uh well our lease is up in May at the
end of May this year and 23 yes this
year yes sir yep sure you guys
yep so we're looking at about you know
June July probably and we can always do
like the month-to-month police too if we
need to
all right I I cannot figure out exactly
what you've got your money in because
it's down more than the market is down
yeah so our portfolio is down about I
live today about 21
um and we have in the last 12 months of
Dow Jones is off seven percent
yeah and again I've been self I've been
self-managing this
um so like I said I mean just doing the
the regular four that you that you you
know teach but again I'm not I'm not
gonna make that that on onto your
teachings no no they're not putting
Mutual put across putting across those
four mutual funds
uh for the short term is never a play
um you had a five-year window and the
five-year Windows very seldom lose money
if you'd have just been in a simple
growth stock mutual fund that followed
the market like an S P 500 as an example
right that's probably what I would have
put you in for saving for a house
instead of across those four the four
are for primarily for long-term plays
and
um retirement accounts and so forth
anyway that's neither here nor there
this is where we are so the the question
is this it is not what you started with
that causes you to make the decision
to pull it
it's what you think it's going to do
right so I mean let's pretend you
started with
um
a hundred thousand and it was worth 160.
then you know you still have to make the
decision do I pull it now
based on what I think it's going to do
between now and may of 23 if it's going
down and then back up and then back down
and it's net down of what I put in which
is where you are I have to make the
decision what do I think it's going to
do between now and may of 23. so the the
past causes us to be emotional but it's
really not your best you know you don't
you don't say well I'm trying to recover
some of the money that's called a cost
analysis and that's always a fallacy you
don't want to use that as your critical
thinking path your critical thinking
path is
I I I reach a necessary ending with
anything an investment a relationship a
job whatever it is when I lo when I've
lost hope for the future
and you don't have to completely lose
hope in the stock market but your hope
would if you've lost hope that in the
next
uh six months from now until May of 23
that the market is going to go up is it
going to go up over the next six months
if you think no then you would get out
today
if you think yes
then you would stay in I truly don't
know what it's going to do between now
and may I have no idea what would I do
if I were in your shoes
[Music]
I would
um I'm pretty risk averse I don't like
Risk
um I the things I buy and invest in are
very conservative generally speaking so
I'm couching my answer in that
I'm probably going to split the
difference I'm probably going to pull
half of it
and let the let the less rest of it ride
until May and let's see if I can make
some back on that but that way I've
limited the the whole stink of things
not going to go down another 30 grand on
me right yeah no way and yeah and so
but I have no idea I mean we've got so
many things affecting this economy now
in the short term that are negative
uh interest rates we they're you know
the FED is doing its best to push us
into a recession to slow interest rate
growth
um they've stated that
um and so what does that do the stock
market not necessarily anything except
if profits go down because consumer
activities go down like buying crap then
uh you're going to see the market drop
more so I don't know uh because we're
being so poorly LED right now on the
economic front that the the variables
that government does control are
screwing up everything
um right I'm being pretty negative so
what would I I would build half of it I
pull half of it and I'd ride with the
other half interesting all right yeah
over the last couple months or so we've
been we've decided to like not put the
money into the mutual funds and that's
right savings I would add no more yeah I
would add no more right exactly and so
this kind of clears things I have some
we've been fighting with the last couple
months now let me let me say really
really loudly because people are I
always get misquoted and misconstrued
and misconstrued and everything
um but so really really really loudly I
am not saying that you should pull your
money out of mutual funds if you're in a
long-term investment situation you're
not a long-term investment situation
you're in a short term
but 100
of my 401K money is in mutual funds the
four types you're talking about and 100
of it is staying there
I'm not moving a dime out of the market
for the long term I have not lost hope
in the market in the long term I just
don't know what the flip is going to
happen with these idiots in Washington
between now and May
they could screw up Christmas they've
still got two weeks to do it but um yeah
I mean it's just you know what I'm
saying it's just I do I'm somewhat
optimistic and with the caveat that
nobody can predict what the Market's
going to do however I'm always half full
I think you're going to see a lot of
companies already doing it you're seeing
a lot of major public companies do
layoffs to get control of their balance
sheet we went on a rant about this last
week to make more profits to make more
profit so I do think you're going to see
the stock market uh I think it's going
to be pretty good first and second
quarter I think things are going to
stabilize there because I do think the
inflation situation and even though the
fed's going to keep bumping the rates
the job markets are very strong I don't
see that being affected so I think it's
going to shake out yeah the real estate
market has slowed down but it needed to
it had to it was overheated that's right
it's not it's not it's not diving or
anything like that it's doing about what
we told you it was going to do it's
going to go up five to seven percent in
23. and would you say the fundamentals
are right for a nice rebound because
inventory is still low I don't think
there's going to be a rebound because
everybody's got their lip stuck out and
it's whining about interest rates and a
lot of people think
psychologically that the market is
actually worse than it really is right
so um you know no I've got a property on
the market that I'm liquidating and they
came in with less than a full price
offer the other day and I told them I'll
wait how long before you think uh the
American house Shopper psyche adjusts to
this new interest rate reality well I
mean let's face it we're all drama
queens
so we overplay the up and we overplay
the down
you know it's like
that's not nearly as awesome as you're
acting like or oh God the world
not as much as you say I mean they
overplay it right and so it's and part
of that is they watch the news too much
and believe what's on the news correct
and uh you know if you're getting your
information from people in the Bathtubs
at the break or walk-in bathtubs you
know you got crazy information all right
so um it's just like I call that
headline hysteria yeah exactly and I
think that affects it more than it
really is so the market has slowed down
we told you it was going to slow down we
needed to slow down the real estate
market so I don't know what stock
market's gonna do between now and then I
really don't but long term I'm 100
have not changed an ounce of that do not
tell people I said to pull your money on
the market because it's going down I did
not say that I was talking about May